[Music]
Genghis Khan paired brutality and
intimidation with Charisma and
Innovation it was that combo that
carried him from a traumatic childhood
to the Helm of the world's most powerful
empire hi I'm rich Burnett for wandrium
and in this episode of perspectives
three presenters discussed Genghis
Khan's Origins his fighting forces and
the women who ran his Empire We Begin
now as Joyce Salisbury introduces us to
a young boy named temujin
life in the late 12th century steps of
Central Asia was harsh
there was endless Warfare between the
various Clans and peoples of the steps
and some of the tribes the tatars the
Turks the carriages and others despised
the Mongols who lived to the north
a queen of the Christian tribe to the
West summed up the attitude of the
Civilized step groups writing the
Mongols have always stunk and worn
filthy clothes they live far away let
them stay there
within this marginalized group there
were always people and families who fell
by the wayside and died forgotten
that should have been the case of an
unfortunate Widow
the tatars killed her husband and seized
the Dead Man's animals and cast the
Widow and her children including an
eight-year-old boy named temujin Into
the Wilderness
everyone expected them to die in the
harsh winter on the step but they didn't
through a series of bold moves the young
boy temujin grew strong and Fierce and
wise he grew up to become Genghis Khan
the Conqueror of the largest Empire that
had yet been seen and this Mongol Empire
shaped the history of the continent
through the 13th century
once he came to a significant level of
power temujin enhanced it and secured
even greater loyalty from the Mongols by
deliberately ignoring the traditional
caste structure of his society that is
instead of choosing leaders to serve
under him who came from the highest
ranking families most closely related to
him which had been the way of Mongol
life since it had come into existence
temujin mostly ignored the elites of his
society and focused on Lower ranking and
low-caste individuals who showed
intelligence and ability
he granted these individuals significant
rewards in the form of food animals and
rights to grazing lands in return these
followers were not only increasingly
loyal to him but they were more than
willing to perform the duties of tax
collecting keeping the men whom they
were assigned to lead in fighting form
and of course they were ready to come
and fight for temujin whenever he called
them to do so
the young man temujin took revenge on
the tatars who had killed his father and
moved on from there
by the time he was 18 around 1180 he had
gained a following of young Mongols who
joined him in raids and battles against
the other tribes his reputation grew as
his successes mounted
hemogen found himself the Undisputed
ruler of a huge stretch of land between
the Arctic tundra and the Gobi desert
but he was not the ruler of this by name
in 1206 he called a kurutai near the
Onan River and the sacred mountain of
burkon kaldun in the hope of making his
status official
the event lasted for days and Drew
tarters Mongols and numerous other
nomadic peoples
the lines of gares reportedly stretched
for miles and thousands of animals were
brought to the nearby grazing lands to
provide food for the event
at this time he decided to unite his
people all his various people under a
new name
or the great Mongol Nation
he did away with all inherited positions
declaring that these were now the
property of this new nation to be given
out or taken away as the leader saw fit
and he also renamed himself
chingus Khan
Ching in Mongolian means something like
strong or unshakable or Universal so
chingus Khan means strong ruler or
unshakable leader or Universal ruler
eventually that name became Genghis Khan
with the more familiar spelling and in
the west it was eventually pronounced
Genghis
now he was poised to organize the many
tribes and Lead an army that could
challenge all the neighbors of the
Mongols of the steps
the great Khan first reorganized the
Army into units based on their abilities
and loyalty to him not on Clan and
tribal affiliation
by his death in 1227 the sources tell us
that Genghis Khan commanded more than a
million soldiers organized into 129
tumans or units of ten thousand men
the heart of this Army remained the
cavalry
every Warrior had five to ten extra
horses so the Army could cover
astonishing distances in a day
sources claim anywhere between 40 and 75
miles in a day
though 75 miles is hard to credit
a Mongol Warrior's kit was rudimentary
it consisted of plain trousers a heavy
double-breasted coat called a deal
fastened with a leather belt around the
waist
a pair of leather or felt boots and a
fur or felt hat
his weapons included a sword and a
dagger for close infighting
a spear and maybe a short halberd
and of course a bow
a small percentage of Mongol Horsemen
wore heavy armor and rode armored steeds
and the heavy Cavalry grew as Mongols
got better access to iron and as they
faced more heavily armored opponents
but the core of the Mongol Army
the life on the step
meant that late cavalry was their great
strength
these young men of the step were far
from the best equipped Army of their
time
but they had two big advantages their
horses and their bows
Mongol Ponies were small and wiry and
exceptionally well trained
a stiff wooden saddle and sturdy
stirrups made the mount responsive and
meant that even in combat the rider had
his hands free to use his bow
a Mongol Warrior could fire six arrows
in quick succession two as he charged an
enemy line two as he wheeled parallel to
it and two more as he galloped away
on campaign a writer would have a string
of ponies of a string of three to five
ponies
he could shift mounts on the ride and
could cover a hundred miles a day
Mongol Cavalry leaded needed little
logistical support and there was no
baggage train
all the horses needed were grass and
water
and soldiers could readily carry their
own weapons and food
Mongol bows are composite recurve bows
recurve referring to the fact that the
ends of the bow curve away from the
Archer when it's strung
in composite because they're constructed
of layers a composite of wood horn and
sinew
the result was a powerful weapon with a
pull that's the strength needed to draw
it of a hundred to a hundred and seventy
pounds
the Mongol bow had a killing range of
200 to 300 yards
the Mongols were also a fearsome Army
because with every enemy they conquered
they learned from that enemy's Battle
Tactics and put them to good use
larger weapons like Siege engines would
be constructed on the spot by Genghis
Khan's group of Engineers recruited from
foreign conquests specifically for their
knowledge of how to build such things
since everything they owned had to fit
in the cart the Mongols did not own much
their clothes were heavy felt and their
Greatest Prize Possession was a huge
iron pot in which they could boil large
amounts of meat
the main adornments for women were
headdresses of feathers and felt women
enhance their status by wearing
headdresses a couple of feet high so
they would stand out and as a
contemporary wrote give themselves a
great luster when they are on Horseback
the images of circuitani and her women
show these dramatic headdresses and the
famous image of circuitani's
daughter-in-law wife of her son Kubla
Khan shows the tall headdress
while the men roamed in the plains
caring for flocks or making War each
woman was in full charge of the cart the
Gare and all its contents
they were the ones who traded for rare
goods from traders in the south
my uncle men didn't want to handle money
or conduct Commerce they left it to the
women
a Persian chronicler observed the
management of the man's Fortune belongs
to the women they buy and sell as they
think fit
the word gear meant home but also
Homeland
so as women guarded the felt home she
had made with her own hand the Khan's
women guarded the Homeland
men could have several wives but each
wife had her own cart and her own
household
Genghis had four main wives and each
wife brought an alliance with a
neighboring territory
as Genghis began to organize his
conquests he entrusted the
administration of the Regents to his
daughters and sons and the sons trusted
their wives to administer their Holdings
as they had always trusted them with the
contents of the gear
the chroniclers recorded speeches
Genghis made at the marriages of his
daughters and these words reveal that he
imagined an equality between husband and
wife he used the metaphor of the
important Mongol cart saying that
through marriage the couple would become
two shafts of One cart which can't move
without both Partners working together
equally
the harsh life on the step demanded the
skills of both women and men and Genghis
imagined the same scenario for his
conquests
when Genghis delegated lands to be
managed by the married couples he gave
tolui his youngest son Eastern Mongolia
lucky for Tollway his wife circuitani
was a more than competent partner to
pull the cart of the state
told Louis spent much of his time
drinking and riding and he left the work
of governing to his wife Circa Tony
but what did they have to administer
beyond the contents of the gares
the Mongolian step didn't offer much in
the way of resources but it laid just
off the most important trading Lanes in
the world the Silk Road which was just
south of the 500 miles of the Gobi
Desert
the Silk Road included a network of
trade that connected China India the
Mediterranean and the Muslim countries
of Central Asia in between
Genghis made some stunning victories
along the Silk Road but his real success
in controlling the whole region was to
require the rulers of those regions to
marry his daughters
but this wasn't a traditional marriage
where women were simply added to a harem
of women no Genghis required the ruler
to divorce all previous wives and to
make the Mongol wife his co-ruler
as Genghis told one of his daughters who
married a ruler along the Silk Road
when I am going on an expedition you
should be my helper when I am Galloping
you should be my steed
and it worked these loyal and talented
daughters secured the lands along the
Silk Road and that was essential for
Genghis to ensure the Loyalty of his
subjects
who began to long for goods to buy
once Genghis had United the tribes
bringing peace milk and meat he kept
them Loyal by bringing new riches into
the nation and these riches came along
the Silk Road
here they could get camel wool blankets
and soft silk that slid on the skin to
replace rough scratchy felt now they had
iron for knives and Flint for fire
even gems and gold and silver ornaments
brightened up the gears and soft carpets
could cover the floors now there was a
reason to expand the conquests and
Genghis did securing the Silk Road and
creating a single trade block
as the Mongol tribe grew in size and
success so did its appetite from for
products so the more sedentary
civilizations
consequently chingus's gaze fell on
China
at this point two non-chinese dynasties
ruled what is now North China
they were the tongit shisha in China's
Northwest and the church in Jin Dynasty
in the Northeast
chingas invaded the shisha in 1209
and made its tongue at Emperor his
vassal
this put the Mongols in control of the
Eastern reaches of the Silk Road with
its Rich Caravans
that same year in the northeast of China
the new church in Jin emperor made a
fateful blunder
church and rulers saw themselves as
Emperors of the sown and also as cons of
the steppe
the Jinn Emperor expected the obeisance
of the upstart Mongol Khan
but chingus was second to no man
he bristled at a condescending message
delivered by the Gin Ambassador he spat
on the envoy before riding off in a
cloud of dust
chingus Khan planned another invasion
the Mongol stormed into the church and
Homeland in Manchuria routed the Jinn
Army at the Battle of badger mouth and
laid Siege to the Jinn Capital jontu
today's Beijing
is one of the biggest cities in the
world and the seat of a powerful Empire
its riches were like nothing the Mongols
could have imagined
Scholars have seen a clear shift in
Genghis Khan's fighting strategy after
the battle of Beijing
no longer did he simply want the stuff
of the other people
rather he began to operate as someone
who was interested not only in
conquering but maintaining long-term
rule over those he had conquered
instead of Simply moving from grassland
to Grassland and letting nature restore
what had been depleted by a grazing herd
he Now set out to carefully maintain
grazing lands
he also set up granaries and other
storehouses for agriculturally produced
foodstuffs and then established a system
of Roads so those items could be
transported more easily throughout
Mongol territory
like other Nomad tribes the Mongols were
illiterate they held their history and
traditions in their memories rather than
taking up valuable room in their carts
for written texts
but once Genghis began to expand his
Empire he recognized the importance of
written laws and traditions he turned to
other literate peoples Muslims Persians
Christians and Chinese to record his
edicts
he specifically recruited a Tatar from
the wigger tribe of Muslims who lived in
Central Asia to record his edicts
he dictated his laws and they were
written in uyghur script on white paper
invented in China and kept in blue
binders
let no one alter the blue writing he
warned
these laws became known as the ichiasa
the Great Law of Genghis Khan and it was
strikingly new in several respects
especially for women
and I should say it was broken by his
sons as soon as the great Khan died
the law for bad torture and intimidation
for as he said the accused must not
confess out of fear and anguish
according to the Muslim chronicler
Rasheed al-din the Mongols tried to
extend these legal protections into
China and into Muslim lands where
torture was routinely used
for women Genghis decreed that women
could not be traded for animals or
property nor should they be raped or
treated as Spoils of War
as I said these laws helping women fell
by the wayside immediately once Genghis
died but they reflect his thinking about
women and his treatment of his wives and
daughters reflected his ideas
when Genghis Khan died in 1227
his greatest Legacy was perhaps the way
he had managed to unify so many
disparate groups of people
uyghurs Huns Turks Arabs Chinese Indians
and more all of these people had been
incorporated into his Empire and one
ethnic or cultural group was not given
preference over another nor were some
groups considered of lower status than
another
his other Legacy as you probably have
guessed by now was a tradition of
warfare and violence
this was inextricably bound up with the
initial Mongol tradition of acquiring
things by looting but had evolved by the
end of Genghis Khan's life to a desire
to conquer and Rule
given that temujin had clearly been a
one of a kind leader the kind that only
appears in history one or maybe two
times in a millennium
you can guess that after his death
things might change
it was his singular genius Charisma
talent and above all his flexibility his
willingness to adapt old Customs to add
new ones and to keep learning that had
made the Mongol Nation what it was
but it was precisely his brilliant idea
to reward loyalty service and ability
rather than kinship that would
ultimately prove to bring the Mongol
Nation to an end
by not clarifying what role his sons
should play in the maintenance of his
Empire or how his most trusted advisors
who were not relatives should proceed
he created Discord and unrest that would
eventually lead to the Empire's end
but that end was still a little way off
indeed it was after his death that the
Mongol Nation reached its greatest size
and power which suggests that he had
created enough momentum to advance the
expansion of his Empire
[Music]
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
now on wandria